Today we are going to be looking at some of
the Top 5 Video Game WTF's.
There are way more than 5 out there, but,
guess what, 5 is a nice round number, and,
it's the number of girlfriends I have.
And by 5, I mean 0.
Definitions: I'm not including things that
are obvious and intended.
And I'm not including things that are fan-made,
but I really wish I could.
And I'm also not including things that are
part of winning the game.
Number 5 is a CoDMW2WTF, and, yeah, it's a
blow up.
But not that kind...this kind.
In Assassin's Creed, MPC's have been found
glitched out, humping the walls at amazing
speeds.
I would be a lot more weirded out if I wasn't
so impressed with their speed.
Look at that.
I want that.
World of Warcraft is filled with WTF's.
We could make an entire countdown just about
them, but let me show you my favorite.
In Dalaran there's a Blood Elf who continuously
strokes a red-hot metal rod.
Let's just take a moment of silence.
If you jump on your Rhino and your barrel
at the same time, you ride the Rhino.
Ride.
Number 1:
I love this because of its subtlety.
It's in Bioshock.
After what appears to be a big explosion,
take a look...yeah...that is why this is number
1.
So, there you go.
To me, those are some of the Top 5 WTF's in
video gaming, but there are so many more.
If you had already seen every clip I talked
about today, give this video a thumbs up to
let everyone know that you are a genius, and
if you've seen others that aren't on this
list, please put it in the comments.
I want to see more of these things, they're
are awesome.
Once you've done that, be sure to subscribe,
and stay Saucy my friends.
(In whisper) Psst, hey, hey are you still
there?
Ok, awesome, listen to me.
There's this really cool thing I found- it's
called Facebook.
I don't know, it's kind of weird, I don't
really get it.
But, we're there, check it out.
There's a link in the description.
Ok, ok, bye.